then he went Donald Trump killed Donald
Trump I love Donald Trump but no more
dropped by the drop boxes are just so
bad no more drop boxes Dickinson
apologic and cephe cephahide
that was about a guy named a rhino named
Mitt Romney Mitt Romney
oh Beauty I had to give the American
people their voice back by
[Music]
truth truth essential
put it against Kate's law and he voted
for Obama
amnesty as you know we've endorsed Dr Oz
we've endorsed
JP right J.D Mandel and he's doing great
I've had more investigations and Jesse
James Billy the could some of the
world's greatest cricket players from
suchin tendulker
as the great religious teacher Swami
Vive come
once said
I hope they now go and take a look at
the oranges or the oranges of the uh
investigation the beginnings of that
investigation and God bless
the United States thank you very much he
was awarded the broad star and the
combat infantryman badge for his service
we have to keep our country gay but but
it's not I mean for some reason it's
just not great anymore if you care about
Law and Order look Law and Order in
normal times roughly 40 percent of fresh
vegetables at about 40 percent China
nambia's health system is increasingly
self-sufficient this is not about virtue
cycling and signing and the great
General and President Ulysses S Grant
he's done he's really come back a long
way over the last 10 years hasn't he
very much Tim Apple when they gaze upon
your semites your seminites towering
Sequoias they delivered a Swift and
swept in you know that sweeping it was
Swift and it was sweeping like nobody's
ever seen anything happen units of
plasma for plasma donate plasma into
failing New York Times by
Anonymous really an anonymous gutless
coward I may ask Marilyn Lockheed
the leading woman's business the teacher
should ever be allowed to teach
transgender to our children while our
parent of himself
no nobody has to have parental consent
and we will totally oppose the Biden
Administration against this
Administration uh he made some
statements rough statements on Jewish
you heard them and you know them well
Trump was doing doing this personal
toilet
s
10 times 15 times
we're looking very strongly at sinks and
showers elements and bathrooms
10 times 15 times
what on Earth is going on with Trump and
toilets
Trump's White House toilet
[Music]
would be clogged
clogged clogged
with documents that Donald Trump was
flushing down the toilet
is this the explanation is this the
explanation
a big mass of dumps
[Music]
10 times
ladies and gentlemen do not adjust your
television it is really 2023 and for the
first time in history a president is
being indicted and will face criminal
charges this is all just such great news
such great news I was proven even more
right than I would have ever imagined
because apparently you know there is
actually igniting my father so great
orange leader maybe I was wrong maybe
prayer does work
[Music]
like communist level
thank you
great communist level this is
great communist level this is a
great communist level
communist level
great orange leader Dear God
forbid Donnie boy God forbid Donnie boy
great orange leader dear God
God forbid Donny boy God forbid Donny
boy
cases
communist level this is a communist
level this is
a great communist level
I think that's about all we need to hear
absolutely ladies and gentlemen welcome
for everybody wondering the album with
many of those songs you just heard and
others will soon be available on Spotify
Apple music tunes and any other
reasonably well-known music platform uh
that is out there very very soon we will
be releasing that album for free for
your streaming pleasure which is going
to be great ladies and gentlemen Donald
Trump has landed in North Carolina where
he will shortly in about 30 minutes
address the North Carolina Republican
convention
facing
536 years in prison theoretically
totaled he will be arraigned for the
second time on Tuesday in Miami Florida
important it's not in Florida it's in
Florida and we will be there on the
Ground Luke the bees knees Beasley is
going to be there for us he will be
talking to users of Truth Central
Defenders of the failed twice indicted
twice impeached former president
um we he may even be coming to us live
during that stream Tuesday so I hope all
of you will be with us then but today we
are all wondering what is Trump going to
say we are going to look at video from
on the ground at the convention we are
going to talk about the charges against
the failed former president I've got a
couple other things up my sleeve planned
um so come on in everybody uh thanks to
everybody who's been signing up via
twitch also I'm going to be going on
Twitch and tipping with bits random
streamers with like under 10 viewers
just to do something nice because it's
like everything's so negative these days
we have an entire party in the United
States a political party based on
debasing the Democracy of the United
States it's just it's all horrible
horrible horrible so just as a nice
thing I'm going to go out and bless some
twitch streamers with very small
audiences uh with some bits in a bit uh
and I don't even know if it is communist
level and I don't know if being
nice is allowed on Twitch but we're
gonna do it so maybe people can tell me
how to find some
um extremely small streams and uh I
would actually say it's cultural Marxism
if you really ask me what it is uh
Rhonda sanctimonious Okay so
where do we start
let's start as follows and thanks Knox
for the um for for the twitch uh
subscription oh by the way new coupon
code indicted again we had a coupon code
before which was just indicted
because Trump has been indicted again we
have scaled up the coupon code to levels
previously unknown and it is now
indicted again indicted again and uh if
anybody uses that code I will make sure
to thank you all right let's get some
Basics on the record I think it's
important to do this just to kind of get
it in one place cohesively and concisely
I'm going to give you my general
thoughts about the propaganda reaction
we've seen from the right to the latest
indictment of trump so if you haven't
been following this Trump has been
indicted federally this is different
than what happened in New York
Trump is facing 37 counts related to
sensitive documents and his handling of
those documents at two of his residences
Mar-A-Lago and Bedminster uh we are
going to
um be delving deeply into the indictment
but in short the indictment alleges
Trump not only uh mishandled documents
he attempted to obstruct the FBI and
grand jury investigation of those
documents obviously you know they uh
moved the documents around spent months
refusing to turn documents over we found
out the surveillance room was flooded by
a Mar-A-Lago employee when they emptied
up they drained a pool into the
surveillance room we don't know whether
that was deliberate but I think I would
categorize it as extraordinarily
suspicious it involves the retention of
classified documents it involves showing
people without the proper security
clearances classified documents Trump
has lied about this endlessly he said oh
I Declassified everything telepathically
or however
but then there are recordings of trump
months after leaving the White House
telling people I can't show you this
document because it's classified this
means Trump didn't declassify it and he
knew he didn't declassify it so there's
so many of these charges Espionage
charges Etc we will leave it to the
legal experts to deal with that part the
subject matter of some of these
documents involves military and weapons
capabilities of the United States and
other countries that's pretty serious
stuff now you can make the argument and
I would defend the argument that we have
a problem in the United States with over
classification I've done interviews
about that I've talked about that I'm
not afraid of that argument however
we're talking about pretty serious stuff
right here one of the things that is not
in the indictment
is what Trump's motive was for this as
we see the Trump motorcade now leaving
uh the Trump plane and heading towards
the speech scheduled to start soon the
uh the document the unsealed indictment
as far as I could see did not speculate
as to the reasoning for why Trump was
doing this so we are all left to
speculate but one of the things that I
think is important to understand is that
the indictment is filled with
evidentiary detail and this brings me to
a very important aspect of this entire
thing which is the aspect of this
relating to Law and Order if you care
about law
exactly law Auto personal
umbrella life insurance business
liability all of it malpractice no if
you care about Law and Order I want you
to remember
that the very same people who are now
defending Trump saying these are process
crimes saying we are over criminalized
saying that this is a Witch Hunt saying
that this is politically motivated all
of those people saying this is not due
process we're demanding Hillary bejailed
absent any evidence of criminality
absent on indictment absent and
adjudication absent a conviction an
absent a sentencing
the very same people who say they are
for Law and Order
are now saying this is nonsense there's
pictures of Trump's bathroom stuffed
with boxes
we have recorded conversations and and
they wanted Hillary jailed they want
Hunter Biden imprisoned they say Joe
Biden needs to be imprisoned and they
have the audacity the gall and the
testicular fortitude or ovarian
fortitude some of them are women to
demand that those people be jailed but
that Trump must be elected president
so you're going to be hearing all of
this for the next several days leading
up to what it seems that Trump is trying
to incite another Riot outside the
courthouse on Tuesday leading up to that
we saw Mark Levin's Fox News Rant
indignant and and all of this stuff it's
very important to remember these are
very serious charges they've got them
dead to rights there are pictures there
are audio recordings it's actually
stunning it's actually stunning the
amount of evidence that there is uh and
meanwhile they wanted to imprison uh
Hillary now I'll say one other thing
you might be wondering David it's 6 20.
aren't you going to demand Trump's
imprisonment for Life sometime soon or
aren't you going to say you you believe
he should rot in jail for the rest of
his life because it is after all 6 20
isn't it time for you to do that and the
answer is no because I'm actually for
Law and Order I'm actually for not
demanding people be imprisoned until
they've been convicted and I'm not for
convictions until there's been a trial
and an adjudication
and I'm not for that until there's been
an indictment which I only want if
there's evidence
okay so my view is not partisan on this
issue when it comes to Hillary Hunter
Joe Biden Obama Trump whoever
if you believe there is probable cause
to investigate then do it they did it
with Hillary and James Comey twice said
there aren't going to be charges because
that's not where the evidence pointed
with Hunter
investigate them indict the guy if
there's evidence he has nothing to do
with the Biden Administration do it
this is the exact same thing I've been
saying about Trump so you are not going
to get me stepping outside of my belief
in due process just because it's Trump
if he's convicted or if it's a likely
conviction and he and his lawyers decide
to take a plea then I will say sentence
him uh appropriately based on the crimes
but they want to tell you they're about
Law and Order
when they're really not Law and Order
means the process I just laid out
probable cause for an investigation
investigation evidence means show it to
a grand jury grand jury says indict you
do you adjudicate if you get a
conviction or a plea you sentence in
accordance with the law
crazy
right crazy
so that's my view
uh on what's going on at this point in
time now we have so many things going on
I want to thank some incredible people
who were the first six people to sign up
using the coupon code indicted again
those are Vincent savageo Joseph Pierce
gifting two subscriptions Cassie long
George Escobar and Jeremy Elias I
appreciate that very much and that puts
us at 14 also thanks to everybody who's
been signing up and supporting on Twitch
that includes our Rhino jgm Kurtz
beachheads tiny sir Jen just gifted five
as well that's three plus five is eight
eight plus fourteen is 22 if my math
serves me uh let's look at some super
chats that are coming in thanks to
Cadillac for the 50 Super Chat
extraordinarily generous thank you
Cody says they flooded the server room
it's beyond parody it's really Beyond
parody Daniel says I think the
difference with Hillary was that the
locker up was more of a rally cry than
an actual expectation as ludicrous as it
sounds well lock up was not unique to uh
to Hillary that's for sure
Tyler has gifted one subscription on
YouTube I appreciate that that puts us
at 23.
business recipe says hey David what type
of material outcome
needs outcomes need to happen from the
indictments in order for it to actually
matter to you what if it's a nothing
burger no the so
we actually I'll go with it it appears
as though a trump appointee is going to
be involved in the adjudication so I'm
already losing confidence in the
adjudication right now it's about what's
in the indictment the indictment is
stuffed with evidence that is damning
Trump had his head by the way you know
how I've said before money really can't
buy taste and we've applied this to when
pictures are published of Trump's Trump
Tower apartment building you know it's
covered in in gold and it's just it's
money really can't buy you taste the
pictures released from Mar-A-Lago
doubly and Tripoli confirmed money
really can't buy you taste this vile
bathroom stuffed with document box it's
it's all com it's hideous it's AB it's
stunning that a guy as wealthy As Trump
can't even get an interior designer it's
it's just pathetic stuff pathetic stuff
David sir Donald Trump AKA Donald Trump
now has big massive indictments
absolutely let's see here big massive
dumps exactly
a big thank you to me for gifting two
subscriptions uh on YouTube I appreciate
that
Dave Willow says is it true he's
organizing a rally prior to his
arraignment in Miami yes and in fact I
think it's very clear that Trump is
trying to generate as much chaos as
possible uh around the courthouse
I think it's abundantly clear abundantly
clear and it's absolutely horrifying
um and he may indeed generate it I mean
he he may succeed uh I don't want to say
January 6th part two but it could get
very very ugly there so we're going to
continue uh continue watching all of it
do you think he will get placed in jail
so good question Shorty at this point in
stock in time I still would bet that
Trump doesn't do a single day of jail or
prison time I think if we got to a point
where there was such a sentence I think
that it would be home confinement it's
just my opinion people write to me if
you're gonna write to me and say I'm
making it more likely he won't serve
prison time by saying this give me a
break guys I what I say on this show is
gonna have no influence whatsoever on
whether Trump gets sentenced to prison
time or not
um and I know people will say no they
have special prisons for high profile
people I'm not denying that it's just
it's just my prediction that's all it is
it's just a guess your guess is worth
just as much as mine so don't get mad if
you disagree you just have a different
opinion it's no big deal my opinion may
change uh and good question in the chat
about Georgia Lori I actually think the
most likely scenario to lead to jail
time is what's happening in Georgia
Trump may get indicted again out of
Georgia we'll we'll talk about that
let's not put the cart before the horse
just because there's so much to discuss
holy crow I didn't know I've been a
member over a year that's awesome you
survived many purges huzzah here's my
question do you think it's worthwhile to
also fight the massive overreact by
Jordan and the other idiots I actually
think it's better to ignore them they're
such losers they're meaningless losers I
think to the extent that we can we
should ignore them Super Dan says David
sir soon it may be time to update
Trump's title I suggest known Trader and
failed former president Donald Trump
yeah he's now twice indicted twice
impeached failed former president Trump
that's where we are right now
and it is an ugly place to be that I can
assure you thanks to Chelsea mooncat for
the twitch Prime subscription as well as
veganzee neverman says Where Were You
June 8 2023 when the beginning of the
end of the Maga movement began do not be
concerned about the upcoming process e
Canon will recuse or be forced to recuse
on prior Prejudice I hope that that's
true and we will be discussing that
super strongly on the Monday show I hope
people are going to watch that show
welcome Napa skip dog appreciate the
twitch Prime subscription hey let's do
something fun just to spread a little
bit of Joy because things are so ugly
right now I'm gonna give some gifts to
random small streamers on Twitch I want
to find people with like no viewers who
are streaming right now and will dump in
some gifted bits any suggestions or
ideas for how I can find such streamers
I think that that would be a really
great thing
um let's see what we should do here we
want live channels let's see who's live
so a lot of these people have a ton of
viewers
let's see who we can find that's not uh
scroll super far down okay let's see
I'll just scroll down far far down
let's see what 317 viewers a lot of
these still have a ton of we're just
going to see if we can do something nice
so this will be interesting because
things have been so horrible
these people have 7 000 viewers
sort by viewers let's see sort by ah
viewers load a high wow that's fantastic
all right let's see Skyrim let's see if
we can find something interesting here
practicing trick shots a lot of gaming
stuff I'd rather find something a little
different where the streamer is on
screen I think that that's really the
critical part of it
uh
uh a lot of two viewer streamers let's
see what we've got
this will be nice this will be fun
just but a lot of this stuff
this doesn't seem like the right stuff
for me
I should go to chat streamer so I can do
category
let's see
language so we'll do English
sir what should I search attack oh up
here
maybe creative
IRL let's see IRL
oh but now I can't sort
just chatting
categories just chatting okay
and let's do viewer oh I can only do
viewers hide alone now but let's see if
I do that and then scroll way down okay
here we go so we're doing now we're
getting somewhere folks now we're
getting somewhere let's see what we can
find here we want someone with very few
viewers very very few viewers
39 let's go even fewer even fewer
I don't know even how to gift bits I
think it's like do I type in cheer we'll
get to that in a moment
let's see what we can find 18 viewers
let's go even lower
how about uh
let's see this is so this is also random
uh
uh how did I'm trying to find someone on
screen how about this random person
Shelly Sofia I have no idea who this is
let's join the Stream
see what's going on now just so how do I
gift bits do I do cheer and then the
number of bits I think I've got like
five thousand or ten thousand bits
available no the stream's not ending
guys the stream just started we're
waiting for Trump we're just giving
people just random people some bits okay
the diamond in the chat box okay all
right here we go after this ad we're
gonna do it
let's just see
let's see what happens here
I have no idea who this is okay
let's do a thousand
ten bucks
is a thousand ten dollars our best
friends
I literally had a lady today and she had
I think she probably is Okay magazine or
a cattle something physical picture I
was like a thousand great stuff thank
you for the follow and and
and Resto
let's see I'm
Chelsea mooncat thank you for the follow
script thank you for the following
[Music]
David
what is going on
[Music]
where did all you guys come from
look at this I'm gonna follow giggle man
thank you for the follow okay surfing
thank you all right follow desert
woodrat let's cut and run all right
let's find someone else now oh how about
that nerd Jacob that seems interesting
let's see what the deal is with this guy
let's see
all right let's cheer 10 bucks
excellent stuff my friend
this guy's not muted is he
yo David yo thank you
thank you so much it's very much
appreciated
get ready for the crowd we're spreading
enjoy guys we got a crowd coming in this
guy's got seven viewers oh my God isn't
this the best yo all right all right I
appreciate this thank you so much David
thank you dark on X twitch monkey 1000
key surfu uh Cole lame bye
all right let's keep going because we've
got to get the to the Trump event don't
leave by the way we're just we're just
giving some people free gifts uh let's
see who else we've got anything that
looks interesting
um here's some people with four viewers
doing some kind of thing
let's see what we got they're looking at
baby pictures I guess
uh you know what I don't even know what
that tickles me the kid on stream is
making me a little nervous so let's
actually
oh God now it's xqc how the hell do I
mute this
all right let's just mute the whole
thing all right let's do one more and
then we're gonna get to uh then we're
gonna get to the Trump stuff let's see
who else we've got
um
Vape Queen I don't know what sort of
content that would be so we're gonna get
away from that
[Music]
um
how about
how about this person let's see who this
is
two viewers okay let's see this should
be interesting
let's tip 10 bucks and see what happens
great work hold on let's unmute oh my
God it is
September
September September oh it's period
I'm gonna get kicked out one day
let's see what happens
welcome in
well oh
when I say I did not expect any of this
I think I mean I would
do they know what's going on everyone
thank you
underwhelming
maybe a little reaction David Pac-Man
show who's
hello
I'm so confused oh this is the best
she seems to be frozen
thank you so much David
how are you all doing welcome in
sorry I was so confused I don't know
what was happening it was
true or not it's all true it's real
today everyone sorry that was just like
wow all right anyway let's get away from
it we're gonna do that again I I have to
tell you I love that we're gonna do that
again because that is just great stuff
we'll just give away we'll just give
away tips to people all right excellent
folks you just witnessed a beautiful
event all right we just gave away 30
bucks 10 bucks a piece to different
streamers I have plenty more bits that
we're gonna do and I I don't know that
was that was great that was really great
stuff people are crying looks big strong
guys with tears in their eyes are now
crying all right let's see what else we
have going on
uh the Andrew fox show says strike and
strike and strike and strike absolutely
I want to say thanks to Desiree Delong
and Juan the troll man uh each gifting a
subscription on my website folks if
you're just joining us we already ranted
and explained a lot of different things
about this new Trump indictment I think
it's really important to mention to you
that this is only the beginning we have
a Republican primary we have a
Democratic president who is uh trying to
justify his re-election Trump is going
to be arraigned and uh in custody on
Tuesday we'll be covering it live and on
and on and on all these different things
I have the smallest requests of you
number one if you're watching on YouTube
hit that subscribe button we're trying
to push towards 2 million subscribers
it's completely free to subscribe on
YouTube if you're watching on Twitch
just follow you know it's really really
simple simple stuff and if you are so
kind
go to joinpakman.com okay you can use
the coupon code indicted again indicted
again and the price is just crumble when
you use the coupon code you can also do
monthly this is all because Trump was
indicted again indicted again so we've
scaled up the discount as we await Trump
I think the the most important thing I
can tell you know we talked about this
with the daily wire before the daily
what the we're actually going to
interview a college professor who
specializes in this very soon the right
is so much more organized when it comes
to Media the daily wire has millionaire
if not billionaire funders and we on the
left are so fragmented and sort of siled
and doing our own thing the best even if
it's not me if there are progressive
content creators you you like
support them if you can just look right
here right side broadcasting network
which is just it's just adject trash
look at this
super chats just dump in they understand
they there's a lot of things I would
criticize the right about they get the
direct connection between we support a
media ecosystem and we win they they get
it the left is not as organized and just
look at this hundred bucks 100 but it's
endless endless endless endless so if
you can sign up at joinpakman.com I
would love it if you just can subscribe
to the YouTube channel that's free
it's the the right has these simple
things hey it's our money shouldn't we
keep the money we make and not pay taxes
wow
so simple send the money send the money
these simplistic ideas hey abortions
murder outlawed well hold on a second
what do you mean by murdering are you
saying Outlaw all abortion what about
the fact that when you ban it people
just get on safe abortions and whatever
right and then they go just dump money
dump money dump money they get it they
get it so I'm gonna get off my high
horse now as we're awaiting Donald Trump
uh but I do want to say thank you to
everybody who has been supporting us
thanks to Emily and robot laser party
Punk on a bike all these great people
signing up over on Twitch let's read
some super chats because they are coming
in uh
that was awesome David thank you yeah
we'll give away we'll give away more
bits on Twitch soon David I'm worried
indictment may be communist burn all
books before woke I know I know
accountability may be communistic Emily
gifting a subscription on YouTube I
appreciate that
um JD says that was great David thank
you Cadillac gifting five memberships on
YouTube
which I appreciate putting us at 39 a
lot of messages coming in
the right is so much more organized if
there's progressives you like support
them says Cambridge analytica appreciate
that
stay woke at 6am for everybody
Peach chain I don't even know what that
means
I don't know what the lingo is
twice impeached twice indicted one-term
loser who am I sounds like scrumps
sounds like scrumps to me I must say
um
people want me to do one more one more
donation you know it's gonna it would
take me a while to get the twitch stuff
going let's do it later let's do it
later I think is what I would say what I
do want to do however is just look at a
couple different things going on in and
around this uh speech that Trump is
going to be doing let's see here
Trump set aboard his plane he will stay
in the race even if convicted although
he insisted he's innocent
uh Trump getting off the plane I guess
traveling with Marjorie Taylor green
oh wait no no Trump snubs her Trump just
snubbed MTG this I have to see
[Music]
[Applause]
Here Comes Trump Marjorie clapping
[Music]
[Applause]
she's awkwardly trying to just walk oh
this is cringe I don't even know that I
can do it she's like yeah I'm part of
this group slowly trying to go oh this
is so cringe oof this is rough
oh boy I'm just walking away she's like
hold on I I want to be with you guys
vile absolutely vile vile vile vile uh
thanks to nasty cues and Cal keys for
the twitch Prime subscriptions man that
my my cringe radar is going hard and I
am struggling to watch that that real
I'm very very much struggling to watch
that
thanks to Nick gelso and Blake Daniel
for signing up at joinpakman.com with
the coupon code indicted again
um oh hey NSA is asking on Twitch David
what's the preferred platform to
subscribe on honestly it's our website
on our website we just pay two percent
to receive payments every other one of
these platforms are taking pretty
sizable slices but
um whatever you want to do is always
appreciated I'm just letting you know
sort of the reality of the situation
super chat's continuing to come in David
sir do you think the pool was drained 10
times maybe 15 times absolutely
endlessly draining the pool into the uh
into the surveillance room let's see
what else we have here's a better view
here's Trump
not even looking at Marjorie
oh man that is rough rough stuff rough
stuff
here's Trump earlier in Georgia
oh his personality you're going to have
wars you're going to be fighting the
whole world really quickly here I just
want to interrupt as you did here the
former president speaking about what he
called election fraud there that Trump
and others have filed and lost dozens of
lawsuits contesting the election
processes vote counting and the vote
certification process in States like
Georgia Arizona and Pennsylvania nearly
all of the lawsuits were dismissed or
dropped with judges I love the little
fact check that's great stuff
I love that Trump called Marjorie
beautiful but Marjorie Taylor agreed
where is Marjorie who's Marjorie
Marjorie Taylor Green is
she would say
hello Marjorie
she's a warrior oh there she is oh look
at her how beautiful
yikes
big yikes happening there geez
um let's see what else we have I mean
the Trump speech by and large we're
gonna
look at on Monday
um
let's see if we have anything else here
here's Senator Josh Hawley
Trump repeating a lot of the same stuff
Trump blames the FBI for the document
dumps
Trump visits a diner
how are you uh look we have to fake news
media
how is everything good I like the Hat he
did a good job before with the pictures
thank you very much thank you everybody
for coming it's a nice
[Music]
[Applause]
crowds on it Mr President
wow yeah I mean listen it it is sad like
it was happening in this country is
extraordinarily sad there's really no
other way to say it
um it is you know
you would hope that at a certain point
we all get to where we say even even the
Trump people they go hey you know what
uh even if I liked his idea of a wall
that Mexico would pay for
we've kind of got to cut it at this
point in time and we're gonna go in a
different direction
and they're actually getting even more
uh sort of behind him and I I'm not
joking when I say this if you really
want to understand what's going on
within the Trump cult right now there
are three books I would recommend to you
all by Jeff Gwynn who's a fantastic
non-fiction author it's Jeff Gwynn's
book about cult leader Jim Jones of the
people's Temple Jeff Quinn's book about
Charles Manson The Cult leader of the
family and Jeff Gwynn's latest book Waco
about David koresh and the Branch
Davidians it is impossible if you pay
attention to the news in 2022 2023
to read those books about those three
Cults and not be drawn in your mind to
analog analogous circumstances to your
average Trump supporter today so those
are three books I very very highly
recommend and you have to understand
cult Behavior
and cult psychology to uh to be able to
answer the question why aren't they
abandoning him and it seems like such a
simple question and in a sense the
answer is simple but it is actually
extraordinarily complex uh so those are
three books just Google Jeff Gwynn
they're on my list at davidpackman.com
I think it's recommendations I want to
say
um check it out check it out all right
thanks to Patrick Heinz Don Navarro
Catherine Collins Nathan Hoffman Tony
narrison who all signed up on my website
using the new coupon code indicted again
let's
um let's do a few more Super chats Major
Payne says I prefer presidents who have
not been indicated yes
absolutely absolutely
David you should get a copy of Larson's
new book of Cults it's old and could be
out of print interesting
I will check that out
um man people really want me to do one
more donation on Twitch all right let's
let's do one more
um
we're just giving random twitch
subscribers uh donations so let's try
this again we're going to go to browse
we're gonna go to let's do like let's
try creative
and then art makers and crafting
what about uh yeah let's try let's try
art
and then probably the most unique oh boy
we'll do viewers load a high
let's see who we have doing art we'll
give one more person just like we'll
we'll send 10 bucks their way
how about
ideally someone we can see on screen
hmm
let's see who we've got here
a lot of these folks seem to be on with
like avatars which I'm not huge on
necessarily
all right this isn't so good
none of these folks seem to actually be
on
hmm
all right let's try instead
let's go back
and let's try creative
and then makers and crafting viewers
load a high
let's see what else we have here
man there's like a lot of
just like seems like cameras just
pointed at stuff
not much going on here's a guy knitting
a sweater
let's send this guy 10 bucks
here we go
okay how much is it for why are my bits
going
what the heck my bits are gone for a
gasoline petrol
what the hell
[Music]
oh he can't get big oh he's not
he's not an affiliate that guy can't get
bits all right let's try one more let's
go back to IRL
and we'll do just chatting pathetic
loser oh god
um
so we'll do viewers high to low but then
scroll all the way down all right let's
find one more here
way too many viewers up here way way way
too many viewers let's keep going
40 nope that's way too much
how about
getting down to 20. okay now here's
where we want to be we want to be in the
15 or fewer viewers range how about uh
what do we have
I think we did that one actually
we're just giving someone a tip who
doesn't have a lot of people watching
them that's all we're doing
let's see who we can find
these people are walking around so we
might not be able to get their attention
five viewers yes exactly
how about
we could do this chess guy should we do
the chess guy
yes no
all right let's do the chess guy
let's join the Stream
this guy also can't get bits hmm
all right
I think we're gonna bail I think we're
gonna bail Trump's gonna be speaking any
moment I'm gonna have a better plan for
that next time I know it's fun and it's
a good time it's just it's proving
difficult to find the right people so
we're gonna they do need to be
Affiliates we're gonna get back to all
of that okay everybody relax let me
thank a few more people here
uh Joshua
chicharricho I hope I'm pronouncing that
correctly Sean heffern Sai Boogie Marina
creminetskaya Kathy horn Shelly McMurray
and our friend Kyoko awaya thank you so
much for signing up on the website the
new coupon code is indicted again also
thanks to Ben a dictator for the twitch
Prime subscription I uh very much
appreciate that other super chats coming
in oh my God Marjorie Taylor green he
just isn't That Into You
Biden should be prosecuted for leaving
classified documents in Chinatown the
last time I had Chinese food my fortune
cookie said my lucky nuclear code number
was
867-5309 great show David appreciate it
Tom thank you
I really wish all of the support the big
names in the Republican party is thrown
back in their faces in the upcoming
years but I really doubt any of them
will lose reputation for this very much
so
Cadillac has gifted five more
subscriptions on YouTube I appreciate
that
um Emily gifted one yeah I already
talked about the Emily gift so I
appreciate that and thanks to OG River
as well for the twitch Prime
subscription let's listen to a couple of
voicemails just to see sort of what's on
people's minds
um whenever you know some Republican
Governor passes that they uh ban in
um of gender affirming care a band of uh
transgender
or vice versa
um the response
response from the left is always why do
you have to worry about transgender
people they're only one percent of the
population and they're right
the problem with that is then they go
and
demand that everybody puts pronouns in
their Twitter bio okay all right all
right let's let's uh I think I think we
got
um let's see if we've got anything else
here hi Jamie this is Bree from Buffalo
New York I was just calling just to ask
you a question about Donald Trump and
his impeachment so how is it possible
legally that a twice impeached president
is able to even still run for president
so he's never been convicted that's how
I mean it's uh you know we've talked
about this before you got to be
convicted you got to be convicted David
sir your last post was so cute everyone
go follow David I think Joseph is
talking about the picture I posted uh
with my daughter on Instagrams I can
only imagine I don't I assume it's not
the hate mail I posted that this person
finds to be cute thanks to Kyoko from
Tokyo for gifting one more subscription
I appreciate that
um let's see if we have anything else
from the standpoint of voicemails here
um
let's see
hey I was reading the indictment and the
thing that kind of popped out at me was
the meeting between Trump and his
attorney where he said hey you know
Hillary's attorney was great he was
great he deleted all the emails and she
didn't get in trouble at all
he was great you know I was thinking if
I was Donald Trump's attorney in that
meeting
and I left that meeting I would be
thinking what the hell is he trying to
say to me it's not you don't even need
to read between the lines there's
actually reporting there's actually
um stuff in the indictment
that says Trump actually said wouldn't
it be better if we just got rid of the
documents that's in the indictment
um so it's it's very crazy very crazy
Paul says at his arraignment on Tuesday
Trump will plead infrastructure week I'm
actually wondering if Trump will finally
release the health care plan on Tuesday
to distract that would be an interesting
Direction
says have you noticed the only person
claiming 45 is innocent is 45 everybody
else is just screaming persecution
without evidence that he's innocent well
no I mean you've got like Fox News hosts
like Mark Levin saying that these are
so-called process crimes and that
they're being unfairly used to go after
Trump and
you have you actually do have a
combination of a lot of different stuff
here's pillow
uh let's get away from that so it there
are other people proclaiming his
innocence they're just doing it in very
unbelievable ways
and and you know bad faith ways thanks
to Christine Ryan Christine just went to
my website and signed up with the code
indicted again I appreciate that also
welcome to Venezuelan Jedi via twitch
Prime you're number 65 today uh here's a
new voicemail that just
um that just popped up let's listen hey
David I'm watching your live stream and
what you said about Colts I think is
right I think progressives should stop
worrying about trying to convince the
other side and start worrying about how
we can get our upside out and how to get
them out in drones and drones
consistently thanks for all you do man
unfortunately
the only way that I'm aware of based on
the cult experts I've spoken to
to deprogram cult members and Mass
um is very authoritarian stuff like what
happened during the Chinese Cultural
Revolution
and we don't want to become
authoritarians you know but here's the
other thing I would say you don't
actually need to deprogram all of the
Trump cultists because we have both the
benefit and the curse in the United
States that like only half the country
votes
so without depro deprogramming anyone
you can actually blow the right Wingers
and the magats or magedonians out of the
water just by increasing voter turnout
now I know it's not like I'm
breaching new ground here everybody
talks about voter turnout every election
and then it's like voter turnout stays
roughly the same but it's the truth you
don't actually need to deprogram all of
them
um okay other voicemails coming in David
this is Kathy horn I just signed up on
your website and then I got the shout
out
I'm watching you on YouTube Casting you
to my TV I just subscribed to YouTube a
couple weeks ago folks it's my first
time listening and I'm really enjoying
the show loved what you did on Twitch
how much fun was that anyway I just
wanted to say thank you and I'm so
excited to have signed up and thank you
for the discount really appreciate it
can't wait now I'm going to hang up and
keep watching the live show folks you're
awesome folks that's what I'm talking
about Obama that's exactly what I'm
talking about that that was a paid actor
I paypaled her 20 bucks right before but
forget about it let's imagine that it
was real uh that is the energy that the
right has
and when Trump talks about a perfect
phone call that's a perfect phone call
see Kathy gets it
thanks to Patrick gabady Kevin langanke
and Jenny Grimm for signing up on my
website number 6667 and 68 today
uh thanks also to senator Larry Craig
great to see you and micro Kimmy for the
twitch Prime subscriptions we're
awaiting Donald Trump originally
scheduled for 6 30 pushed to 6 45 and
now clearly delayed even further
let's continue uh checking out super
chats oh no we don't have any other
super chats that's okay let's get to
some other
voicemails
uh recently Mr Pac-Man uh
[Music]
I that was French I can anybody say what
did that guy say he wants to start a
news in politics YouTube channel and
wants advice from me was that what that
was
my French isn't that good
I think that's what he said let me
listen to it once more
recently Mr Pac-Man
um
[Music]
I think he said what he wants he said
first he said hello to me and then he
said what he wants to ask of me is that
he's interested in starting a political
YouTube channel
can anyone confirm does anyone in the
chat speak French please
he wants to know why I started a YouTube
channel my inspiration oh okay
no other people are saying he did ask
that he wants to listen you know what I
don't know why anyone would leave me a
message in French
I really don't know leave it in Spanish
if anything hey David it's Coley Culp I
already tipped you in chat but I just
want to say it just one more time for
everyone in the back
they fought in the server room
Cody really really really enjoying the
fact that the server room was flooded
yeah I mean listen I'm with you I'm with
you hi this is Jackson in Baltimore
Maryland
um I think the Trump trumpers have a
point that uh Donald is being treated
unfairly
um because he is I mean he's being
prosecuted for crimes uh where most
other rich and powerful people are not
right this that's a perfect point they
talk about the two-tier justice system
and they want us to believe it's one for
Democrats and one for Republicans that's
idiotic we've had a two-tier justice
system for a long time
and it's the wealthy and the elites and
everybody else
and what's happening is
Trump is at least theoretically being
held accountable
at least theoretically in that he's
being indicted we'll see how far it goes
beautiful voicemail beautiful voicemail
uh okay I see people demanding voicemail
from Whitney I do have some thanks to
booters 1957 for the twitch Prime
subscription here is a uh a Whitney
voicemail
so I wanted to kind of like rag on quote
mothers for a bit just because I was
looking at this like oh debatable Clause
of like maybe you're a mom maybe you're
not maybe you're a bad mom maybe you're
a good mom or whatever and it's like
people like hardcore defend like crack
addicts who are scissors and then when
it comes to somebody who's like oh well
maybe I have to like wait a bit until my
kids are in bed to be considered a good
mom like if I if somebody smokes weed
then it's like I don't know maybe all
right sort of an unusual stream of
Consciousness uh Whitney called right
back with more
but like growing up I had so many
babysitters
it like wasn't even funny like uh
so many times my mom left okay you know
what I'm not gonna do this right now
actually I'm realizing this is not
appropriate right now
let's let's not just let's just not do
it right now okay
um jeez
thanks to Beth Graham for the twitch
Prime subscription super chats continue
to dump in Carlos says David the real
crime is the discount you're giving away
on your site with the new coupon code
you might be indicated indeed if you're
just joining us today is maybe the best
day I can think of in history to support
Independent Media with the coupon code
indicted again
I get emails from people who say David
listen I support you on every platform
you must have somewhere like five ten
fifteen percent of your audience
supporting you no we have roughly 0.7
percent of our audience that supports us
on any platform if we could get to just
one percent it would be huge be part of
a positive one percent you can sign up
with the coupon code indicted again and
I will thank you if just one percent of
the ten thousand people watching right
now were to sign up
we hit our goal instantly which is
actually crazy uh let's see other super
chats Mike says is this proof that there
are two Justice systems I would be in
jail from day one why is he not can we
file a petition if I were to ever be in
this position can I be like you didn't
put him in jail no
no you can't yeah obviously Trump well
Trump maybe buy I don't I'd actually do
the question about bond is a good
question
it's a good question
do you think Biden should pardon Trump I
mean it could be good for his campaign
no
David is a Canadian Brit it's important
for Americans to know that to the rest
of the world Trump will forever be known
as traitor to the entire Western World
America has betrayed the entire free
world yikes yikes
I like my presidents like I like my
pickles uncharged wait let me see if I
have that
here it is uncharged piccolos
warm food around noon there we go those
were the days huh
David will you be my new therapist Lord
people find you and it brings them back
to Childhood trauma oh boy I don't know
if that's a compliment or not
a Tiffy Kitty says David sir I'm coming
to you with tears in my eyes truth
sensual is a trumpster fire and the Maga
meltdown is in full swing it is indeed
it is very much in full swing big thank
you to Shane white Martin Barrett Jana
Gallatin for signing up at
joinpakman.com new members 73 74 and 75.
John says the algorithm has indicated
this channel is worth watching cheers
sir been a fan for a bit now hey that's
a actually let me do some quick feedback
on both YouTube and twitch
let me know in the chat if you're here
just type in like let's just have a code
Type in
47 type in the number 47 if you're here
because YouTube or twitch randomly
recommended this stream to you today
people are typing it in before I said
what the the rubric was
no no I didn't mean just type in 47. I
meant only type 47 if you're here
because this was randomly recommended
and you heretofore had no idea who I was
oh God everybody's just typing 47.
oh dear God
all right forget it forget it okay type
in zero zero eight if you meet that
scenario zero zero eight if you were
randomly recommended this stream today
oh there are some okay that's not bad
that's not bad
I mean that's what this is all there are
there are actually quite a few that's
great
that's great we're not trying to just
preach to the choir here you know
uh and everybody who's typing zero zero
eight is lying okay good super useful
super useful thanks to Susan armino
Marcy Martinez Gregor emand
and uh yes for signing up at
joinpakman.com I appreciate it man that
backfired horribly backfired horribly in
the picture of documents in bathroom one
of the boxes says Mar-A-Lago bedroom or
m-e-l Melania I don't know I don't know
I'm gonna look into the I want to look
at the pictures more closely
strike and strike and strike says Devane
edict I appreciate that and welcome to
irie man over on Twitch let's listen to
what's being said Trump will be speaking
momentarily
a future without Joe Biden a future led
by President Donald J Trump are you with
me let's make America great again thank
you North Carolina God bless you and God
bless America these people are sick sick
cultists
[Music]
seven lonely days
this is this is beyond parody
you were gone
don't know why you'd run what you're
running to or from
all I know is I want to bring you home
I I just can't I can't do it I can't do
it welcome to David Garretson and Amanda
Amanda conlon who just signed up at
joinpakman.com I can only imagine what
these people are saying let's listen
this way that's great and we're gonna
hear what Poe and and the president
spoke about which is going to be awesome
uh you know I know Beau is a young guy I
guess he played some college football
too I saw some of the uh the bio there
it'd be nice to hear from him and what
he wants to do next uh he probably
should have been the winner of course if
you're wondering who these people are I
think what's happening is right side
broadcasting was on the ground in
Georgia earlier today for Trump's
deranged and delusional corrosive speech
there and so I think they had their a
team in Georgia and then I believe this
is probably the second stringers
um
that's my sense that's my sense of
what's going on but I can't say for sure
I want to say thank you to jack Allah
for the twitch Prime subscription and a
huge thank you to S Prez who just gifted
50 subscriptions via twitch putting us
at 132 let's go for 150 absolute massive
dump of membership big massive dumps
super chats are pouring in and so are
voicemails let's just see
if I can get a couple more voicemails in
they're saying
[Music]
they're saying I know the saying what I
was joking about was this fool me once
shame on shame on you
fool me we can't get fooled again that
was the reference I know the line I know
the line but it was a reference to that
classic George W bush moment moment okay
other super chats reports are saying the
boxes in Trump's bathroom were full of
David packman coupon codes that wouldn't
surprise me
that wouldn't surprise me
um have you ever had Sam Harris on your
show for an interview yes find it on my
YouTube channel widely available
wide-ranging interview by the way I
don't even know
you guys know that I don't really like
pre-promoting interviews because they
interviews so often either get canceled
or they get postponed
damn should I even do this
you know what I'm not even I don't even
want to do it this time listen
um
we've got a really great guest that
we're close to booking that
I think is going to be
I think it's going to be very very solid
for the show I think it's going to be a
really good thing for the show and it'll
be an interesting interview as well okay
so I'm going to leave the tease I mean
it's sort of like vague booking I have
to tell and I don't want to derail and
and you know
one of the things I find super annoying
is when someone I know on Facebook
will post something like
could really use some positive thoughts
today
because it's not going well
and that's it and then everybody's in
the comments trying to figure out oh is
it like that are are you sick did
someone die what's going on did you lose
your job or like did you miss out on
Taylor Swift uh tickets and that's all
that's going on vague booking
okay could really use Positive Vibes
today
I don't like it you know it it feels
desperate for attention and I know some
people go oh but it might be someone in
a tough position where they're not
comfortable saying it's really annoying
guys I'm not saying there's no example
where it's like logical
but I don't like it okay I'm against it
I'm against it it's not good
thanks to Elizabeth Elrod Amanda
blindbre
seal jankola for the website signups I
really appreciate that so so much
thanks to miss scorp Arizona as well as
irie man for the twitch Prime
subscriptions let's keep alternating
voicemails and super chats because
things are things are really happening
here I hate to say it but I miss George
W bush I never thought I'd say that says
Tara
thanks for the 20 Super Chat Fade to
Black David do you believe Donald J
Trump's claim that Biden stored 18 000
boxes in Chinatown it was 1800 boxes I
don't someone someone wrote To Me
and said David think about the size of
the boxes that are in the Trump pictures
figure out the volume and multiply by
1850 think of the warehouse size you
would need to store that many boxes and
I think that that is a fair criticism of
that claim I think it's a very fair
criticism of that claim
other super chats coming in
let's see what else we got here
hey David this is Sean hefferon a long
time follower grateful for everything
you do thank you sir hey I just
purchased a gift subscription and
thought it was one that was going to get
donated to the list but it can go to
someone directly so I thought if you
could give me a shout out on the live
now and have someone message me directly
I can send it to someone who's watching
right now uh best to reach me Instagram
oh okay no no no listen if you if you
don't fill that out
we will gift it to someone you don't
have yet when you gift a subscription
It'll ask you if you want a gift it to
someone if you just leave it blank it
just goes into the queue the last thing
we're going to do with you know 10 11
000 people watching right now is blow up
your you're gonna get even if 90 of the
people that contact you are nice you
don't want to do that just leave it
blank and we will we will get it all
taken care of Don't worry
um let's see what else we have here
uh hello sir you made a tweet earlier
which I found hilarious that when
somebody asked about the Trump bathroom
story
you're gonna have to say which Trump
bathroom story and I just can't believe
that that's the point uh We've Come to
in this country
uh you know is it the massive dumps is
it the flushing of toilets 10 times 15
times is it the elements of bathrooms
anyway
it's Insanity big massive dumps yeah no
that's absolutely true I did tweet that
earlier now when the Trump bathroom
story is mentioned you have to ask which
Trump bathroom story is it the time when
during the campaign he was obsessed with
sinks showers and toilets is it when we
found out he was flushing documents down
his White House toilet and clogging it
or is it when he stacked boxes of
classified documents in a completely
gaudy classless bathroom at Mar-A-Lago
right next to his toilet there are three
bathroom stories related to Donald Trump
which is just it's it's out of this
world out of this world insane
fool me once shame on you fool me twice
I put the blame on you fool me three
times F the peace sign load the chopper
Let It Rain on you that's a quote from
Gandhi not a quote I'm familiar with
try a live stream like this but with
producer Pat sometime the logistics of
that are difficult
um okay couple other
voicemails coming in hey David uh this
is Jeremy a fellow Latino Jew and I just
wanted to sort of send along a thanks to
giving me a blueprint earlier in my
political Evolution to sort of
understand the context of more
left-leaning politics from uh Latino
perspective I'm from Venezuela I know
you're from Argentina so it's a bit
different context there that grew up in
an anti-left household
and got to move away from that sort of
dogmatic world view and I think that's
really cool and that's it thanks so much
like viewing the live stream all right
beautiful message beautiful beautiful
message
um
let's see what else we've got David
I'm a long time fan
I didn't want your content though
recently for about four or five months I
went through a nasty divorce sorry to
hear that I'm back now and it's good
that nothing's changed your content's so
amazing your sense of humor is awesome
and Whitney is still leaving voicemail
yes yes so keep it up man we all
appreciate it Whitney is still calling
in still calling in that is absolutely
right
um
let's see
hey David Sean hepron again big mistake
gave you a handle for one of my other
um uh social accounts it's at SLS okay
trying again and we're not gonna do that
definitely don't want to do that don't
want to do that don't want to do that
welcome to Lester Dale and Rhonda Hudson
who just signed up on my website if
you're just joining us we are moments
away from hearing Donald Trump tell
corrosive lies to an audience of cult
sycophants
mostly old white dudes quite frankly is
what's in the room okay fine but I think
we just have to call it as it is and uh
that's totally fine that's the audience
that is going to welcome these uh cult
uh corrosive statements we have a new
coupon code it is called indicted again
as you see right above me indicted again
is the coupon code reading about nukes
while taking a Duke yeah that should be
the theme I guess of Trump's uh
prosecution David why aren't you talking
about the aliens yeah you know I got
some interesting feedback the other day
I played a voicemail from someone who
said that I have not been talking about
the fact that a whistleblower claims
that there have been intact alien
spacecraft recovered
and that I'm scared to talk about it and
my view was like listen it's sort of
interesting but there's a total absence
of evidence a total absence of evidence
and one of the things that I I am still
struggling with and I I'm curious
whether people in the audience are
struggling with this
if indeed you know the the Whistle the
so-called whistleblower it's interesting
okay but the Whistleblower says
for decades now intact alien spacecraft
have been crash landing on Earth
is it likely this is just like a does it
pass the sniff test thing is it likely
that there are
alien societies
so Advanced to come to Earth over a
period of many decades
yet they constantly are Crash Landing
okay no one notices from the standpoint
of the public
somehow multiple governments are able to
keep the secret
and over decades they don't figure out
how to stop crashing
like it doesn't really make sense
it's very tough for me to believe that
that's happening
and I'm right there saying that
statistically
it does make sense that there is
intelligent life in the universe if you
just think about the size of the
universe the number of galaxies the
number of planets the number of planets
that likely could support life of the
kind we know the possibility of planets
that could support forms of life that we
don't understand I'm right there like I
think it's statistically likely there is
life on other planets somewhere in the
universe but it's very hard for me to
believe that for decades the super
Advanced aliens that can get all the way
here from who the hell knows how far
technology far exceeding us keep
crashing don't fix whatever is causing
them to crash and no none of us notice
and also there's no evidence that has
been you know actually made available
all really weird really tough for me to
believe that that's happening call me
crazy
call me crazy thank you to Chad Harris
Beverly Bedard dexie Co
for signing up on my website using the
coupon code indicted again I appreciate
that very much
um
let's keep going with some of these
super chats co-worker came to me at
lunch today Tears in their eyes and said
sir do you want a sandwich salad combo
too I indicated that yes I would love
the lunch combo and thank you
uh that sounds great that sounds great
is this Trump what's going on here
no it's not some other way
who is this
what a great crowd we've got here
tonight
really odd way of clapping extremely
strange just just downright bizarre
other super chats I'm afraid the more
they wave the American flag the more
racist it will look to do it don't want
our country to become like Britain in
that sense I don't know that much about
the connotations of the flag in Britain
that's actually interesting interesting
to be hearing that
um
let's see what else we have here
have you heard anything from Jimmy from
Philly lately I have not in all fairness
we have 3 000 unlistened to voicemails
and it's become I will never get through
it I will never get through it it'll be
I'll listen to the most recent 10 like
on a stream I've actually given up you
know this is actually something
interesting with email I'm like really
good at inbox zero and I'm all over my
email and part of it is my actual email
address gets very few emails like all
the public emails and all that stuff
like they're managed by other people but
I've essentially I know of people who
have given up with their inboxes where
they just said like I I'm deleting it
all uh with the voicemails at this point
it's sort of like maybe I'll get to five
percent of the voicemails because there
are so many we're talking about
thousands and thousands at this point
all right uh they're playing a
propaganda video in the room so Trump
will be speaking soon let's see if we
can squeeze in just a couple more
voicemails or thank a few additional
people Kathy horn has just signed up at
joinpakman.com and his new member
143. today is the day
fight these lunatics
and help Independent Media at minimum by
subscribing to the YouTube channel it's
so simple guys this is where we are
we're fighting for 2 million the only
Progressive YouTube channels at 2
million or higher are our friends at The
Young Turks different category right
they have like 50 employees and our
great friend Brian Tyler Cohen
and then it's us
help us breach the 2 million mark
as the corrosive twice indicted twice
impeached failed former president
prepares to take the stage
other super chats what do you think the
Federal indictment from the January 6th
riots will be like I don't know let's
not put the cart before the horse here
is prompt
yep we'll get to it very soon
uh actually we may even take this over
on Newsmax oh it seems Newsmax isn't
even taking it that's that's actually
really funny
just make mildly smarter people work to
get the discount those are the people
you want the code should be Little Don
Mighty get big indictee have fun with
that geez welcome to Rob Griffin new
member number 144 today very much
appreciate that a couple other super
chats is that Trump it's okay David they
all look alike to me too
Anita I actually my contacts need a very
small tweak very very small tweak and
then I will probably be able to better
identify these guys thank you for
inspiring me do you think it's more
important and impactful for people to
vote in Municipal elections not an
either or vote in every election for
which you have an opportunity to vote it
is that simple
don't forego any election
thanks to duck Co for the twitch Prime
subscription very much appreciate that
um we've got other let's put a pause on
the voicemails because Trump is about to
speak it's funny when Trump walks out on
stage too early and has to wait for a
while while the song plays
[Music]
and as you can see he's hinging at the
waist and and sort of swaying back and
forth
extraordinarily disturbing imagery
um how long do I expect them to go I
really hope it's under 90 minutes but I
worry it will be really long like a
castro-like speech
ERS
I think we actually do need a different
feed because I'd like to get all of this
uh stuff let's see if right side
Broadcasting
German is a big deal here we go how is
it the heck
where's the video
tremendous success here
we won it twice
we won the primaries twice we won the
election twice it was great sit down
come on let's we'll be with each other
we have nothing Ronda sanctimonious
I also want to thank our outstanding
nrcc chair
man where is the chairman Richard Hudson
where's the chairman
we just got back from Georgia and he's
even a celebrity in Georgia
we had a great crowd in Georgia too
he's fourth in line for speaker and his
wonderful wife Renee is incredible and
she served four years actually in the
White House says kellyanne genuine here
of kellyanne Conway nobody right nope
she's so fantastic but thank you and
thank the family your family is
fantastic we appreciate it thanks also
to one of the great stars of the party
one of the great stars in politics
Lieutenant Governor Mark Robinson
weaponized extremists
terrible
and I'm going to endorse walk but I'm
not going to tell you about it tonight
okay
we'll save it for another time but you
can count on it Mark congratulations
great job you've been doing a fantastic
will you
oh God I also have some Warriors that we
fight together with all the time and we
win a lot we win most of the times
Representatives Dan Bishop was dead
thank you Dave
thank you Dan these are really horrible
thank you very much great job
great job we love them
Chuck Edwards chuck chuck
thank you Chuck thank you thank you very
much
and state house Speaker Tim Moore Tim
thank you very much
great job
Tim is doing a fantastic job thank you
for seven years we've been engaged in an
epic struggle to rescue our country from
the Sinister forces who actually hate it
and want to destroy it I really believe
they want to destroy it if you're
talking about Confederate reason these
forces are far stronger than Russia
China North Korea and Iran all put
together because with the Right leader
you saw that just three years ago
we have the right leader all of those
countries are absolutely no threat
they're not any threat to us we talked
about it before
right now however they're putting us in
the most dangerous position in the
history of our country we've never been
in a position like this there's never
been such danger it's because of the
Weaponry the power of the weaponry
and we have people that have no clue
we're people in office
that have no clue together we stand up
to the globalists we stand up to the
marxists what globally we stand up to
the Rhinos I wish you would name a
single Marxist because you don't know
where they're coming from the rain the
Rhinos you don't know where they're
coming from we stand up to the
Communists and the environmental
extremists because I'm an
environmentalist I really believe that
we've done some great things for the
environment but you have extremists and
you don't know whether or not they're
really serious about some of this stuff
it's not even believable
we stand up to the open borders does
Trump know that that liking Marx
Brothers movies doesn't make you a
Marxist sell all this partisan
prosecutors and the fake news media we
have a lot of it back there but not all
of them
[Applause]
that's a big group back there by the way
Dan I think they're here for you maybe
and on November 5th 2024 we're going to
stand up
to the corrupt political establishment
we're going to evict a totally corrupt
president named Joe Biden from the White
House
well and we're going to finish the job
that we so successfully started probably
there's been no more important four
years than we had we did a great job all
of us together in a sense things we did
nobody thought were possible
I put everything on the line I will
never yield I will never be deterred I
will never stop fighting for you never
and if I wasn't leading in the polls by
so much we'd have no difficulty
and you know they're the party of
disinformation they say oh we want to
run against Trump in the meantime we got
5 000 prosecutors after us
because they don't want to run against
Trump we beat him the first time it's
called evidence of crimes second time we
beat them we did much better the second
time
more than any other president more votes
than any other sitting president has
ever gotten and more votes in terms of
the margin from 63 million and add
millions and millions no presidents done
that usually they get less the second
time you know you get tired of them they
weren't tired of me because we got many
more votes with your vote we will take
back our country from these fascists and
Thugs and we will indeed make America
great again left-wing fast this time
from the beginning
our America First agenda has been an
existential threat to the rotten
political class that gets rich and
Powerful at your expense erasing our
borders cheating like we've never seen
before in elections
exporting our jobs and squandering our
blood and treasure on endless Foreign
Wars we didn't start any wars first time
in 71 years no Wars they all said Trump
will get us into a war he's got that
personality no it was my personality
that kept us out of wars
[Applause]
though we finished some Wars we finished
Isis 100 of the caliphate we knocked out
Isis we did whatever we had to do and we
were respected all over the world as
Warriors I went to a Billy Joel concert
once and he opened and he said hey
everybody I don't have anything new to
play for you and everybody cheered quite
frankly and so did I because that's
great that's what you expect from Billy
Joel uh Trump could be saying the same
thing quite frankly it respected us they
respected your president and it's less
pleasurable when it's Trump's same old
lives
and it's very sad what's happening
they've launched one hoax
these people we have to deal with
and they've launched Witch Hunt after
Witch Hunt
and they just tried to stop our movement
they want to do anything they can to
thwart the will of the American people
it's called election interference that's
what they're doing now this is election
interference
and we've never seen it on a scale like
this
and you have to understand the other
side is downright crooked
that's why we now call them
crooked Joe Biden because you know we
took the name away from Hillary she
suffered enough with that name there you
go
so I retired the name from Hillary
because I want to bring it over to Biden
because he's probably worse than she
ever was said that's saying something
as the Durham report proved they spied
on my campaign the Durham report did not
prove that no surveillance warrants the
FBI offered one million dollars for a
fictitious dossier written
by a foreign spy to try and frame me for
treason we beat it all off didn't we
they put our country through hell and
they knew it was a lie the entire time
they knew it was a lie they knew the
laptop from hell was a lie they knew
everything
remember it's not me
they're going to go after
and if you think of it
whoever took my place and I hope it's
not going to be anybody because we're
the ones that are going to save this
country because our country is in
trouble
they'll go after that person and that
person will not be able to withstand the
fire and I know all of them
I know them all and they actually admit
it they come to me how do you stand this
and I usually look at them and say in a
sick way I sort of enjoy it
because whoa it exposes them
it exposes them for what they are and
it's also lifted the poll numbers to
even higher legs have you seen this the
pulse are through the roof and the
fundraising small dollar fundraising is
setting records
but still you get indicted over nothing
you get indicted over the presidential
records act which they don't even admit
they call it the Espionage Act
these are sick people
we had I prepared everybody for this
earlier this is part of the minimization
of the fact that Trump is charged with
very serious crimes books number one
remember the perfect phone call
impeachment hoax number two
the illegal censorship of the hunter
Biden laptop from hell
the 51 intelligence officials who
falsely said it was Russian
disinformation remember they said that I
said nobody believes that who would
believe that you see the pictures
horrible pictures the real pictures
haven't been exposed yet
but all of this and it just kept coming
and coming and coming and it would for
another
person in my position but they wouldn't
be able to handle it they wouldn't be
able to take it because you're dealing
with crazy lunatics
now the Marxist left is once again using
the same corrupt doj and the same
corrupt FBI
and Attorneys General and Local District
Attorneys to interfere in our election
at a level that our country has never
witnessed before
these criminals cannot be rewarded they
must be defeated we have to defeat them
soundly
in the end they're not coming after me
they're coming after you and I'm just
standing in their way that's the grift
no they're really going after Trump
they're not going after random people in
the audience
the baseless indictment of Me by the
Biden administration's weaponized
Department of Injustice
will go down as among the most horrific
abuses of power
in the history of our country I think it
already is when you think about it
and certainly going back to Obama when I
said you know they spied in my campaign
everybody I'm turning the fake news
media back there they said oh that's so
crazy it turned out I was right he was
not right this vicious persecution is a
travesty of Justice
you're watching Joe Biden try to jail
his leading political opponent think of
it this is like third world country
stuff there is no evidence whatsoever
Biden is doing anything he's leading him
by a lot
wants to put him in jail
over following a civil act this is a
simple thing the presidential records
act It's all under the presidential
records act as it should be It's all
under the Clinton Sox case you know what
the Clinton Sox case is that's where
they
sued Clinton and he ended up winning
that he could keep
the things that we're talking about it's
all under that Mr congressman
but this is more like stalinist Russia
or communist China that we're dealing
with these people
have
reached a level of trump derangement
syndrome that nobody thought was
possible
very low energy
and I never thought frankly that this
could
happen in America
you go after a president that got again
the most votes by far of any sitting
president in history gets out of office
and because I'm running if I wasn't
running wouldn't even be talking about
it untrue if I weren't leading
we wouldn't be talking about it varying
by a lot we are leading to sanctimonious
by Massive numbers he's he's heading
south quickly no personality you've got
to have a personality to win he's got no
personality
and you know remember that riveting when
he came to me he had virtually no votes
no he's dying as the expression goes he
was a he had virtually an overall George
Washington could endorse you it wouldn't
matter no sir if you endorsed me I'm
telling you I'm going to win I said
let's give it a shot that was he had
virtually in a role shortly thereafter
they had the primary
anyone and then we had to get him
through
a crackhead
but nobody knew he was a crackhead at
the time at the time he was the hottest
politician in the Democrat Party male
version
female version Stacey Abrams
true
Stacy Abrams
and him just uh that they just
advertised some crazy fake medicine it
was the thing that was just on the
screen was Bonkers and I did
three rallies massive massive massive
rallies thousands and thousands of
people
and I said you're going to win and he
ended up winning
and then they started cheating at the
end you remember all the votes were
disappearing over days 10 000 here
Rick's got same thing and I called in
you wouldn't believe if the FBI
would you believe it
and it stopped
so at least they did something right
but I got them in and then they said to
him
I say congratulations Ron I didn't know
him that well he was one of the many
people that supported me during the
impeachment hoaxes these are really
electrifying stories as I know everybody
in the chat can tell
three years later they said would you
run against the president
and he said I have
I have I said I got this guy in Mr
congressman and he said he's going to
run
and then I haven't been very nice to him
since then
we're leading in Florida by
28 points by a lot I'm not happy with
him and he's a lousy campaigner remember
that
when he came to see me he had almost no
points he was ready to look for a new
career you told me that better than
anybody no he was working for a job
and when I endorsed him it was like
magic it was like he was a rocket ship
but I believe in loyalty and you know
that's just very disloyal if somebody
got me into office just as a little fact
check it actually took about three
months after Trump endorsed DeSantis for
desantis's polling to really improve not
that we care but it's just like all of
this is lies different some people I I
help a little bit some people I help a
lot but some people I get in I got this
guy in so you know you think there'd be
a little bit of a loyalty and it's bad
for the Republican Party frankly but
let's see what about Pence
but we're leading by a lot but meanwhile
Joe Biden and
had troves and troves thousands of
boxes classified documents from his time
as vice president
and even as a senator and boy when
you're a senator and you take classified
documents that's a big deal I watched
Dick Durbin get so angry about it when
you're a senator and you do it it's a
big deal when you're a president I guess
it's not but he went out and Senator
Durbin he said you can't as a senator
take
classified documents out of his skiff he
took him out of a skiff as a senator
it's unheard of I spoke to a lot of
senators they said I don't believe me a
lot of them got a lot of them they
didn't believe it
and they come after me
and we had a great we had a wonderful
operation everything by the presidential
records act we were talking to Nara
but you know nara's radical left you
know they have a red flag on the
Constitution of the United States
and in the Bill of Rights you know what
red flag is it is a dangerous document
this is where Nara is coming from
and uh
they're very really they've done
I would say over the last number of
years very poor job but they're very
very radical left so you have to be
careful of these people
but they conspire with the FBI they
could this is all it's it's so untrue
that it's extraordinarily shocking that
a former president is even willing to
say these things
um this is also a very strange delivery
Trump seemingly at the edge of
completely losing his train of thought I
took on hundreds of billions of dollars
in taxes and tariffs from China think of
it no other no other president took in
any money any money not not just as a
reminder American companies pay the
tariffs that are put on Chinese products
at this late stage of the game Trump
still doesn't seem to understand how
tariffs work at a fundamental level
that's the place
and he's getting money based on reports
currently and of the media the fake news
was doing their job they'd be
earning Pulitzer prizes which no longer
mean anything you know I'm suing the
Pulitzer Foundation there you go that
because
they gave Pulitzer Prize
to reporters from The New York Times And
The Washington Post
because of their wonderful and accurate
reporting on russia-russia Russia but
they were wrong
in fact the Durham report just said how
wrong they were but they were but we
knew that even before the Durham report
right many of them have already conceded
the fact that they were wrong
and they have Pulitzer prizes
we want those prizes taken back
and we want them maybe reissued to other
people like
like Greg Jarrett
like John Solomon like all these people
that actually did call it right that is
so they were real reporters they really
did a great job
but they have to take those back and so
we're suing them and we're suing them
for damages because they're labeling me
by saying that these people
can I'm not a betting man I would bet
none of those lawsuits go anywhere other
than the toilet in the papers themselves
have now admitted is a hoax
that's libeling me because they're
saying that it continues to exist so
let's see what happens with that but we
have to bring back our country we have
have to bring back sanity into our
country you know the media is so
important they could straighten things
out so badly
so quickly look if 15 years ago
15 years they're like a policing agent
they should be 15 years ago 10 years ago
if somebody said that somebody was
taking money from China and from Ukraine
and from all these other places
I love this Super Chat how does he still
need a teleprompter for this speech I
can recite the whole thing the man is a
broken record yeah then he'll go and you
know when I am back in the white house
we are going to defend parents rights
think of it think of it who would have
guessed it was even a thing we would
have to defend parents nights no no no
but we're gonna do it and we're gonna do
it very quickly very very quickly and
then he'll do you will we we will ban
men in women's sports and no teacher
will be allowed to teach transgender
without parental consult I'm sorry
without parental consent we're not going
to do it we're just not nasty guy
but they're all nasty because they're
deranged
but we have to have our great media be
policing agents so that things like this
can't happen because you know there is
no Scandal without press if the Press
refuses to write that Joe Biden got five
million dollars and a lot of us you know
it's terrible out there they had this
swimmer you know and they try to beat a
record by a sixteenth of a second
women's swimming they have all these
women they're fighting for a sixteenth
of a second and then this guy comes in
30 seconds the wind burn for the swimmer
next to them and now it's a terrible
thing we're not going to allow we're
going to end it right day one day one of
my presidents with a few congressmen we
have stuff that's so Earth shaking and
you put out the announcement and you
think it's going to be headlines in the
New York Times And The Washington Post
on every paper and every ABC which is
real fake I call it ABC fake News NBC
fake news CBS fake news
but you put it or I put fake in front of
every one of them we know and nobody can
say it's not it's like they're
coordinated they're totally coordinated
they use a word like they had a word not
so long ago manufactured the votes are
manufactured every station said the same
thing it's never been used in politics
before nobody ever said votes are
manufactured every one of them
we want to report that the votes have
been manufactured you turn to the next
one ABC the votes have been managed it's
like somebody sends them a memo what to
say what's he talking about they were
honest our country would be in such
great shape
amazing okay now
because you'd be in jail it's no
coincidence they indicted me the very
same day it was revealed that the FBI
hit explosive evidence that
Joe Biden took a 5 million dollar
illegal bribe from Ukraine this is very
much untrue
hasn't read anything about it this would
have been the biggest story in history
10 years ago
Walter Cronkite would have reported it
and he was on the liberal side to put it
mildly but he would have made this the
biggest story but we don't have Walter
Cronkite anymore do we walk the
cronkites the Walter cronkites and the
great ones are gone
right as they're closing in on Hunter
and Joe Biden
they want me to
put up with this form of Retribution
like nobody's ever seen before but it's
okay because the public is smart you
know what's amazing how smart the public
is I go through the town I was always
doing well not his followers right I
mean we did great with the uh you know
all the votes we got the most ever for
sitting president but I was doing great
I've never had receptions we just left
Georgia
and we had a room that was I mean
they've never had anything like it and
there were thousands and thousands of
people outside trying to get in for the
Republican Chairman's lunch not normally
the biggest thing now because Michael is
so outstanding of course this is a big
deal of course but but you know Michael
right the streets
tremendous crowds at the airport waiting
the airport being very far away from the
venue where it was people all along the
roadway and this is not really campaign
season people are disgusted with what's
going on it's indictments they want
America back they want America back
so I've been predicting this for a long
time just like I did with live you know
live golf I told the players take the
money to Rocco and me say thank you very
much
should I take 185 million dollars say
yeah take it
but sure that means I have to leave the
to it don't worry about it take it
because three things are going to happen
they can emerge which I predicted they
would and it was nice they actually
covered me very well they said it was
like really good but they're either
gonna this really is super relevant to
the crowd obviously in one case got 185
million dollars great when Dustin
great player Dustin Johnson
Brooks kepka these guys we're you know
they're great but you know
lots of others were offered hundreds of
millions of dollars they said no and now
there's a merger and I actually made the
statement I said if there's a merger and
you don't take the money you're gonna
have a lot of very unhappy golfers out
there
very unhappy golfers out there but it
was exactly as I said
but I call this one too
and
I said that Hunter will
probably be charged with some minor
offense like jaywalking
so that the FBI and the doj can pretend
that they're Fair
oh we got Hunter so while they're going
after me under the Espionage Act
that's like the creation of missiles in
your basement
they got him for nothing
and there's never been a more corrupt
group of people in the history of our
country running this country this is
wild if somebody sits on a board gets 83
000 a month a three million dollar
upfront payment
nobody's ever said anything like this
and in all fairness was interviewed on
one of the shows
on
main television I call it Maine used to
be
serious television now it's main
television main television I said uh no
I don't know why they paid me so much do
you have expertise sir and
oil and gas it's an oil and gas company
no I really don't do you know anything
about it no
then why are they paying you 83 000 a
month and three million dollars in
upfront payments so we think it's
actually more than that
but these are corrupt people these are
corrupt he had no answer
he had no answer
the money laundering the sounds like a
crime bribery and the other massive
crimes
they all implicate crooked Joe Biden
see how good that name works because you
know Hillary's now finished let's assume
although she's probably going to try and
make a comeback after this speech she'll
probably try but I don't think she'll be
very successful she'll be like wow that
speech was so stupid I've got to run
against Joe
the stakes of this election could not be
more Stark either we have
a communist state you know they used to
use the term deep state I'm stopping it
I'm using it Marxist I'm using it
fascist I'm using Communists Because
deep state is far too soft
I would love for Trump to Define Marxism
once just one time and then I'll give
him credit and be like you never have to
Define it again you're allowed to use it
if you can Define it once other
Venezuela but on steroids big scale
version big large beautiful scale
version of Venezuela how about we're
buying oil from Venezuela
when I left then Venezuela was ready to
collapse we would have taken it over we
would have gotten to all that oil it
would have been right next door
but now we're buying oil from Venezuela
so we're making a dictator very rich can
you believe this nobody can believe it
you know where the well you know their
oil is garbage it's horrible the worse
you can get tar it's like tar and to
refine it you need special plants and
these people are talking about not doing
or we have liquid gold the best most
beautiful stuff you can get liquid gold
better than gold right under our feet we
have more than
imagine with everything we now know
thinking we should further the amount
that we just drive around burning fossil
fuels into the air like okay fine give
us an off-ramp we've got all these new
technologies but the idea of like let's
do more it's crazy
what we had done is amazing but with
Venezuela they put their oil and they
refine it in Houston so all of those
pollutants go right up in the air
we don't want to take oil because we
want to watch the environment but we'll
take the worst car in the world burn the
crap out of it create oil and watch it
go into our atmosphere
so the environmentalists have no problem
with that so we lose economically and we
also lose from an environmental
standpoint because it is really dirty
stuff the dirtiest stuff you can imagine
we take it from Venezuela and we also
make the country strong again
and the head of the country is a
dictator
it's not even believable some of the
things that are happening I have to tell
you this is as deflated as I have
probably ever seen Trump oh go ahead and
vote
that's why they have all these people
coming and they think they're going to
be able to vote the funny thing is a lot
of them turned for Trump
you know a lot of them on the Texas
border towns wouldn't that be funny we
like Trump the best
we like Trump
that the governor of Texas called me
right after the election he said you've
done something that's unprecedented you
want every single town along the border
mostly Hispanic he said that hasn't
happened since he called it
reconstruction I said is that Civil War
would you say that Civil War that Civil
War you know turn we haven't heard in a
long time reconstruction but hadn't
happened since reconstruction Civil War
but it happened we did incredible we're
doing incredible with Hispanics at the
end of the day either the Communists
destroy America or we destroy the
Communists
and and who are they exactly
and never forget what the demented
persecution of our movement
is all about our enemies are desperate
to stop us because they know that we are
the only ones who can stop them we're
the only ones who can do it small group
relatively small group
but we couldn't stop them called and we
will and we would have had them stop
cold and they know that and they cheated
like dogs they cheated like nobody's
ever cheated before
you turn on your television at 10
o'clock you would have said Pennsylvania
is a lock we were up by so much a lock
all of a sudden you see that big fat
dump that big dump at 302 or whatever it
was it's a disgrace what happened what's
happening to our country but I promise
you this
if you put me back in the White House
their rain will be over and America will
be you guys remember that 3 A.M dump on
Election night
the dump talk re-energized the crowd
more than anything else
thank you very much
I stand before you today as the only
candidate
who has what it takes to smash this
corrupt system into truly drain the
swamp
he happens to also be the only candidate
under two indictments and that's why
disinformation we want to run against
Trump
we want to run home
they run against
we killed them last time they know it
killed him with Hillary how about that
one you think that was a little surprise
That Shook them up they said we'll never
let that happen again so they developed
all sorts of read the New York Times I'm
not a fan of the New York Times but read
New York Times certain stories but read
in particular Time magazine cover
from a couple of years ago because they
couldn't
help themselves they had to take credit
for it what they did was so bad for our
country and look at our country now look
what we are we're dying
anyone else will be rippedish Reds
there's no issue as I talked about on
Monday check out my segment it's hard to
find an economic indicator that signals
a major problem right now it's actually
difficult really bad Biden economy our
economy is sick everything is sick
but remember and it's true 100 percent
they will not be able to withstand the
fire
for three years Joe Biden and his
corrupt allies in Washington have waged
economic Warfare on the hard-working
citizens of our country Biden flooded
your communities with millions and
millions of illegal aliens look at
what's happening to our country right
now
crushing American wages and stealing
American jobs I believe that you don't
hear this number I think from wages are
up uh way more than they have been in
decades and unemployment is at a record
low we'll have come in
to our country
he launched a vicious crusade to shut
down American Energy
Anwar
think of Anwar and Alaska Ronald Reagan
couldn't get it done nobody could get it
done so many years so many decades I got
it done
the first day they terminated Anwar
would have been bigger than Saudi Arabia
at least the same size would have been
bigger so good for Alaska
would have been the biggest in the world
we were going to make so much money
we're going to pay off our debt
we're going to reduce your taxes still
further remember I gave you the biggest
tax cuts in history the biggest
regulation Cuts in history
thank you
but we would have made so much because
oil and gas is such a big business such
a big big business such a powerful
business and such an important business
New England as a liberal tint but we're
taint I would say taint is a better word
it has a paint it's a little bit on the
liberal side they say but they pay the
highest energy prices in the United
States because they're afraid to build a
pipeline right through New York state in
a poor region where people desperately
need the gym a pipeline would bring down
New England numbers by 50 or 60 percent
but nobody wants to talk about it
Biden spent trillions of dollars on
socialist lunacy causing the highest
inflation in 52 years
since Biden took off as the typical
family has lost over stink of this
remember inflation has been coming down
for about six to eight months you will
each year income
job
his number one job was
as next president what he wanted to do
he just everybody that talks and they're
right we want to reverse
what Joe Biden's done he's been a horror
show right
show he's been a horror show from the
standpoint of our country
and what he's done in terms of
our military right he's given away 85
billion dollars worth of equipment
the best equipment in the world to
Afghanistan they're now one of the
leading sellers of military equipment
anywhere in the world some people have
them at number two because they don't
need seven hundred thousand brand new
rifles
they don't need 70
000 Vehicles many of them armor plated
think of your friends that have a used
car lot and think of them as big that
big if they have 300 cars in that lot
it's a lot we gave away 70
000 some of them costing millions of
dollars Vehicles armor plated four
inches of armor
under my leadership we built the
greatest economy in the history of the
world in fact we did it twice
and now we're going to do it again and
it's going to be better than ever we're
going to do it again really hard to
believe
as president I ended years of bitter
betrayals of North Carolina workers
North Carolina was hit very hard by the
Democrats
I withdrew from the job-killing
trans-pacific partnership would have
killed your state
a globalist Calamity that would have
killed American Manufacturing
forever I stopped at in I'm convinced he
has no idea what he's talking about and
neither does the crowd this is
essentially a performance where neither
the speaker nor the audience know what's
being said
uh I think philosophy would have a lot
to say about these sorts of events never
made nobody thought because you have
people I don't know where they get their
thinking but you know they get it from
lobbyists and lots of other people and
it's hard to get the votes even when
something is
really good
and we replaced it with the U.S MCA
that's the Mexico Canada
trade deal and you know how I know it's
good because they are working feverishly
to try and renegotiate the deal because
they're getting killed remember we
analyzed usmca it really differed from
NAFTA only in some minor ways including
percentages of parts and labor and car
production but it was not hugely
different from NAFTA which Trump said
was a disaster or bring in hundreds of
billions of dollars pouring into our
treasury from China when no other
president had gotten anything from China
they never got anything
they got a lot of that's what
they got whoa
[Applause]
and when China targeted our Farmers I
got China to give our Farmers 28 billion
dollars who do you think else is going
to do you think Joe's going to do that
hey
president XI you've really been screwing
our Farmers you got to give us got 28
billion for the farmers that's why I say
I'm not losing Iowa
somebody said how you doing in Iowa I am
up like 35 points but I said how could I
lose Iowa I got 28 billion for the
farmers in Nebraska any Farm state
you were you took some big chunk out of
that 28 billion too by the way when I'm
back in the Oval Office I will revoke
China's most favorite Nation trade
status hmm that'll be a big deal
when he takes over and remember they got
that because they said they were a
developing Nation well you know what
honestly we're developing Nation our
cities are going to hell we have to
redevelop our cities or our country is
going to hell
look at our cities look at New York and
Chicago and Atlanta Atlanta has the
highest crime rate per capita of any
City Atlanta
where they're trying to get me on a
perfect phone I don't know if that's
true people kill people and they never
even get interviewed
but let's get jump a perfect call a call
that was so good it was actually better
than my perfect call with the Ukrainian
precedent so let's keep
it was more perfect
but think of it I have many lawyers on
this call
Diverge I have many lawyers on this call
Brad raffensberger was other call I was
calling to complain about the election
because I say it was rigged and had good
reason
but we were there many lawyers I said
things that was at the call Henry
future calls were going to be and nobody
said sir you shouldn't say what you just
said what a horrible thing we just
talked
what I said was perfect sure actually
perfect could not have been better most
people have read it they've said oh
what's wrong with this it's just a con
job
they can't they're all disinformation
misinformation secunda
if there were a problem with that call
these state lawyers would have said sir
you're not allowed to say that would you
please take it back
this came up long after the call was
made
it's like John Lovitz remember John
Lovitz on Saturday Night Live he's
probably a trump hater but I'll use his
name anyway the liar they called him the
liar yeah yeah I went to Harvard that's
where I went I went to Harvard I'm a
businessman that's right I'm a business
man
well they did it too they said I'll
probably do another 15 minutes I mean
it's just it's the same speech we were
wondering whether he would talk about
the indictments in any serious way it
doesn't seem he's going to I am a little
curious if he does this thing where he
addresses the specific people in the
crowd or brings them up but uh it's hard
to believe there's value in two more
hours of this but let's see
they would have been screaming
from the rafters how dare you say that
sir you're not supposed to that girl was
perfect I complained about election
fraud and I wanted them to do something
about it and they should have done
something about it but they didn't
we will gain total independence from
China we will make the United States the
manufacturing superpower of the world
and we were starting to do that
tremendous money was coming in and to
your state it's coming into
it was coming into North Carolina what a
what a place under Biden we've
had record high trade deficits which I
call losses a lot of people don't say oh
a trade deficit isn't a loss I call it a
loss
some just remember that the United
States has run trade deficits dating
back to the mid-1970s it has to do very
generally with how we have arranged our
service sector our manufacturing sector
and our energy sectors it has nothing
specifically to do with Joe Biden it's
been trade deficit since the 70s very
successful businessman then I did The
Apprentice and I did lots of books that
were big big big big sellers even now I
have books that are tremendous sellers I
never had
I never had this stuff in mind I never
had the word indictment
what's indictment mean sure that's when
you're extremely dishonest sir
no these people are con men and we have
deranged people running it
for this reason I will pass Landmark
legislation
because we have to save our country to
be known as the Trump reciprocal trade
act there you go you know what that is
no when China charges us a 150 percent
tariff
we charge them a 150 percent right now
they charge us
right now so we charge them nothing they
charge us a hundred people in the chat
are asking how is Melania still with
this guy after everything there are
reports that he's basically just paying
her at this point to stick around I have
no idea if it's true I quite frankly
don't follow that sort of thing very
closely but there are reports that
allege that but their name stupid trade
I said Pat so let me ask you John is
charging us 150 percent
tariff on various products can we charge
them 100 nurse sir it's not free trade I
said how about a hundred percent they're
at 150 what about no sir you can't do
that what about 50 you know sir what
about 10 Pat no sir you can't do that
that's not free trade these are the
dumbest people I've ever seen right
it's called an eye for an eye or a
tariff for a tariff
but isn't that a beautiful thought
because we're getting screwed by every
country of the world and I need to get
this one approved by Congress
and they prove things easy if they're
bad things if they're not politically
correct they don't want to do but this
is politically correct this is very
simple they charge us we charge them
what's going to happen is a lot of them
will come off
because they say what's the use of us
collecting 150 if they're going to get
100 so it's coming but some won't do
that and that's okay because we'll take
in a fortune but we'll make Trade Fair
in a day really in addition because
we're the pot of gold but we're rapidly
losing that pot of gold status soon
we're not going to have anything
we're losing so much money in addition I
think we should have about a 12 to a 15
tax on anybody that comes into the
United States this is a tariff if they
want to do business if they want to take
our wealth if they want to steal our
wealth from us they should pay 15
percent
it's not that high a number it's not
going to stop them we'll make a fortune
and we're going to become a prophet
making machine so easily really
doesn't seem super likely
because remember we have 34 trillion
dollars in debt got to pay it off and we
don't want to do anything stupid but if
we uh do the reciprocal trade act that's
fantastic and if we do a uh you know
we've had people smart people that said
if we are going to sell our wealth to
other countries we should charge them
for it why should we allow other
countries to come in and steal our jobs
to make our cars to make our computers
to make everything and then just sell
them right back at us with no tax no I
think if we do that they should be
charged 15 percent
the numbers that you're talking about
are astronomical and we will become
overnight a tremendously successful
country and many jobs when you do that
will come back into the United States so
I want you to think about that that'll
be very controversial tomorrow in the
fake news because it's such a good thing
think about that they're gonna hate it
think about it
we're going to fight the globalist
vultures and the Washington swamp just
as we did before and we're going to win
we're going to have tremendous victories
I said we're going to beat Hillary I was
right I said we're going to beat
Biden I was actually more right
kind of lost we're going to beat him
this time and we're going to watch those
votes kinda you know with covid you
couldn't go there you people sent in the
votes to get all these ballots they send
in the votes tens of millions of votes
coming out going in nobody knew what the
hell they knew what was happening
but uh we can never let that happen
again remember this Jimmy Carter and
he's a nice man and I know he's not well
so I'm not going to say anything
but Jimmy Carter had a commission and he
said you can't do mail-in ballots if you
have mail-in ballots it's going to be
Rife with fraud
of course it's going to be Rife with
fruit this crowd is pretty damn dead
guys pretty dead
ballots
and we can't do it can't do it we're not
going to have a country left France used
to do it they got out of it because they
said it was so fraudulent and they went
to paper ballots same-day voting voter
ID and you know what they had an
election they got 36 million votes
they had a winner they had a loser and
that was the end of it
very simple a lot of people you know it
sounds
too simplistic but paper ballots they
make certain Watermark paper that's
phenomenal stuff it's actually
interesting great practically advanced
paper if you can believe it but we
should do paper ballots we should do
voter ID and we should go back to
same-day voting we should also have
what's up just one day we don't need
even if you call it Trump voted weeks
early by mail in 2020. well if you know
this we don't need to have
48 days of voting
[Applause]
and just remember they created a lot of
ballots
they had places where there were
more ballots than there were voters
and they had a hard time explaining it
but the courts don't like to get it
there is no place where there were more
votes than there were voters that we
know to have strong elections and we
have to have a strong border it's no
wonder the swamp is getting truly
desperate as they see us leading big in
all the polls in this week's morning
console poll just came out we have a 34
point lead on to sanctimonious
we're at 56 percent
that's with a lot of people in it
Haley's at three
great job Pence is at seven
oh look at this one this one just came
out in the clarity campaign poll very
respected
we're leading by 56 points that doesn't
mean we have 56 that means we're leading
Ronda sanctimonious by
56 69 percent for Trump 13 for the
Sanctus
and Pence Essex you know once you get
used to saying to Sanctus it's hard to
say to scientists I was actually being
interviewed and I was trying to be
serious and I called them to Sanctus I
said that's not good but he's changing
his name you know now it's D santis
and I put a little message out never
change your name in the middle of a
campaign
you don't change your name in the middle
of a campaign
in the Emerson poll of Iowa we're
leading by 42 points see I told
I got him 28 billion dollars how are we
gonna lose
that's a big lead in Iowa we're going to
do great in Iowa we've always done great
in Iowa and we're leading Biden by a lot
in the recent Fabrizio swing state poll
of Arizona Georgia Michigan Pennsylvania
Wisconsin oh God we're in almost 50
percent of the vote already
almost every poll he mentions I've never
heard of or is a known terrible poll we
think you'd be leading him by 40.
you would think it would be leading him
by more than we're leading the Sanctus
in the ABC Washington Post poll
just came out I'm up by seven points
over Biden OVA and the new poll from
democracy Institute very respected shows
that I'm the only candidate that beats
crooked Joe Biden
and DeSantis is losing to him by a lot
with each passing Day More Americans are
joining our patriotic movement
we are having unbelievable I didn't hear
a mention like you know morning consult
or SSRS or even Fox News does good
polling Believe It or Not gee people are
saying you can't weaponize you can't do
this
together we've achieved more than anyone
thought even possible we delivered the
largest tax cuts in history we delivered
the largest regulatory Cuts that's why
we had the greatest employment numbers
ever in history we achieved energy
Independence we were soon going for
energy dominance where as I told you
before we're going to be paying off
massive amounts of debt and lowering
your taxes still further because that's
the kind of numbers you're talking about
when you get the oil cook
in 60 years think of it we had the worst
the worst problems and the worst costs
in energy in 60 years we headed down to
a dollar 87
three and a half years ago a gallon and
we actually had it lower than that but
we won't even talk about that because I
had a safety oil companies they were all
going to go bust I said this is the
first time I've ever said we got to get
it up a little bit I actually called
Russia and the king of Saudi Arabia we
had a three-way call
and we cut back on the oil because it
was so incredible help fill up the
Strategic National reserves and he's now
taken all of that to reduce
gasoline prices for cars just prior to
the election this is riveting officially
and is reduced it down to the lowest
level that it's been in I think 60 years
we created the most secure Border in U.S
history built hundreds and hundreds of
miles of border wall
was going to build another 200 miles to
fill up some gaps that we saw
and then they
came in after a very strange election to
put it I'm trying to be nice
a very strange strange election really
bad election but they came in and they
didn't want to fill up those walls so
that's the first time I said these guys
actually want to have open borders
we got Mexico to give us 28
000 soldiers free of charge that's how
we succeeded you know we had the most
secure Border in the history of our
country all right we've heard this story
a million times so listen we did 15 more
minutes we're getting to nothing new
whatsoever uh so we're just gonna cut it
we will be live for the arraignment on
Tuesday Luke Beasley is going to be on
the ground for us in Miami and I expect
it could be pretty Bonker stuff so
please do join me on Tuesday live and
between now and then we're going to
publish so much content but nothing new
here from this guy the same old hits and
they're not really hits they're really
old flops at this point in time hard to
believe anybody could believe it we will
uh see everybody Monday for the show
Tuesday for the show and then Tuesday
for the live show as well alright
everybody see you then there are plenty
of ways to continue watching this if you
so want to torture yourself continuing
tonight I would recommend not doing that
we'll see him on day